vous avez sûrement déjà vu le jerki
industriel à la caisse du garage ou
encore du dépanneur mais il se fait
maintenant artisanal et séduit une toute
nouvelle clientèle j'ai rencontré des
gens qui tentent de lui redonner ces
lettres de noblesse
[Musique]
c'est l'histoire d'un garçon qui rêvait
au cabane et mangeait du jury quand on
était jeune avec mon frère on mangeait
ça en allant à gun cuites
on mangeait du Joky que notre père nous
achetait c'est du Jack Lings of comme ça
et c'est aujourd'hui l'histoire de Fred
et sa famille qui produisent du Joki ou
si appelé charki
on se dit pourquoi on ferait pas une
compagnie nous-mêmes j'ai développé des
petites marinades simples et
avec le temps on en fait plus d'habitude
le Joker
c'est une meilleure qu'on a jamais fait
ça
donc avant même les cowboys se mangeait
les conquistadors sont arrivés et puis
ils ont trouvé ça c'est les Incas qui
faisaient ça et les Aztèques ça
s'appelait le sharkoui c'était deux mots
que chars
plus dans les Amériques du Nord et puis
les Américains étaient pas capables de
dire le mot que ça s'est transformé
charcuy en jerki
[Musique]
ou non le dieu qui américain industriel
et la référence
si à Saint-Eustache on le fabrique de
façon artisanale
pas trop faut quand même une certaine
épaisseur que ce soit intéressant
consommer surtout en collation le jerki
est riche en protéines une portion de 30
G offre de 10 à 15 g de protéines on
prend un peu de viande trop grosse faut
pas qu'il y a degrés là-dedans pour la
conservation aussi suite de ça c'est
juste de faire une bonne marinade un
certain niveau de sel un peu de sucre
pour cacher le trou du sel que la dent
c'est un jeu là-dedans entre le sucre et
ensuite de ça on le fait déshydrater
assez pour que ça soit vraiment
comestible que tu ailles tué toutes les
potentiels bactéries et que ça peut se
garder un certain temps
au Canada plusieurs entreprises en
fabrique de façon artisanale au moins 7
compagnies québécoises tentent de percer
le marché depuis les dernières années
c'est quoi la différence entre le Joker
plus artisanal celui plus commercial
c'est vraiment les additifs je dirais
que c'est surtout ça fait que on parle
de nitrite nitrate
à scorbate de sodium toutes ces choses
là qui font que au final le jokis garde
plus longtemps et se stabilise plus
facilement artisanale c'est un peu plus
compliqué à stabiliser mais on sent que
c'est plus authentique aussi on
travaille plus sur la saveur mais c'est
pas des saveurs travailler chimiquement
avec toutes sortes de produits
riches en protéines faibles en gras
facile à transporter et à conserver un
avantage non seulement pour les cowboys
d'antan mais aussi pour les randonneurs
d'aujourd'hui on voit souvent le Joky à
la caisse au dépannage au garage et bien
sûr à l'épicerie mais aussi dans les
magasins de sport
pourquoi on le consomme quand on est
sportif de produits là pour surtout pour
les gens qui font de la randonnée la
longue randonnée la randonnée courte la
protéine issue de la viande une protéine
qui se gère lentement pour la longue
randonnée c'est vraiment ça qu'ils
recherché donc avoir de l'énergie sur
une longue période donc c'est sa
particularité je pense contrairement à
ce que les gens pensent c'est bon pour
la santé parce que c'est juste de la
protéine pure il y a pas de gras à
le plus de sel de sucre c'est le
peut-être que ça peut être néfaste faut
pas faut pas abuser
Dieu qui de bœuf poulet gibier mais il
en existe aussi à base de saumon et
végétalien quand j'ai vu Portobello je
me disais ça doit pas être très
soutenant il y a moins de protéines que
les produits à base de viande oui comme
la moitié moins à peu près pour le même
poids
les versions VG souvent aux champignons
ou à la protéine de soya contiennent de
5 à 7 g de protéines par portion de 30 g
c'est quoi les bons indicateurs d'un
produit de qualités
[Musique]
il y a plus de sucre dans certaines
saveurs comme le teriyaki le Sweet
barbecue
bizarre
concassées la première fois je mange du
bison
zéro gras c'est vraiment bien fait aux
États-Unis j'en ai mangé du Joky de thon
des joys lapin de l'autruche du cerf ici
on est c'est facilement introuvable
du crocodile
vraiment à n'importe quoi
compter de 10 à 13 dollars le 100 g et
un peu plus pour le jeu qui au saumon au
végé
le fait c'est salissant aussi les
ingrédients ça dépend tout le temps les
ingrédients et on commence une
production de 50 kg on se ramasse avec
25 kg et peut-être moins de viande donc
on parle de 50% de pertes et 60% par
dépendamment si la viande est bien
gorgée d'eau ou pas vers l'intégrale des
recettes il y a plein de randonneurs ou
de campeurs qui vont utiliser les la
nourriture déshydratées en sac donc ça
peut être un ajout super intéressant à
mettre dans un Mac and cheese vegan par
exemple ou dans un riz pilaf donc juste
pour augmenter la quantité de protéines
du plat puis l'agrémenter le Hangout
aussi le couper davantage tu mets sur
des salades sur des pâtes des choses
comme ça ma mère des fois ça arrive que
à cuisine qui a fait des omelettes puis
mélenchères à l'intérieur de l'omelette
vu que c'est une protéine qui est déjà
lentement on va le conseiller le prendre
au début ou pendant la randonnée pas
attendre la dernière minute parce que ça
va maintenir un bon niveau d'énergie on
est très très loin de celui qu'on trouve
au dépannage
qui ont bien changé et les cowboys aussi
[Musique]
lui c'est lui